هل كانت هناك لحظة دكتور فاوتشي عندما
قلت حسنًا ،
هذه هي الزيادة الكبيرة ،
نعم 40 زيادة في مستشفيات نيويورك
خلال 24 ساعة فقط
، هذا رقم كبير عندما رأيت ما
حدث
في شاحنات التبريد في مدينة نيويورك
يتم تعبئتها الآن حيث تعمل مؤقتًا
تقريبًا
تجاوز نظام الرعاية الصحية لدينا
كان مثل
يا إلهي وهذا عندما أصبح من
الواضح جدًا
أن القرار الذي اتخذناه في العاشر من كانون الثاني (يناير) بالبدء في
تطوير لقاح
كان لدينا عدد من المرشحين للقاح
ربما كان القرار الأفضل
لقد قدمت فيما يتعلق
بالتدخل بصفتي مدير
المعهد
[الموسيقى] ،
فإن اللقاحات المنقذة للحياة وتحطيم
الأرقام القياسية التي أشرف عليها الدكتور فوشي
كانت نجاحًا هائلاً للأطباء من
أجل العلم والعالم
ولكن تذكر أن اللقاح يفعل  لا
شيء للمريض الموجود على الطاولة
في هذه الحالة ، يمكن لمئات الآلاف
الذين لقوا حتفهم قبل العلم أن ينقذهم
عندما تنظر إلى بياناتك الآن
وتعتقد أنه حسنًا ، لقد
خففنا في وقت سابق  لقد توقفنا بالفعل في
وقت سابق وفعلنا ذلك في
الواقع إلى أي مدى
تعتقد أنه كان من الممكن أن يكون
جيدًا ، أنظر إليه بهذه الطريقة في المرة الأولى
التي لدينا فيها عذر لحدوث
حوالي مائة ألف
حالة وفاة نتجت عن تلك الزيادة الأصلية
جميعًا  الباقي في ذهني
يمكن أن يتم تخفيفه أو تقليله
بشكل كبير